Dobby's true identity was finally  revealed in the anime he is actually  Toya Todoroki the eldest son of number  one Pro Hero Endeavor and the older  brother of Shoto in the past Endeavor  told Toya to stop trying to be a hero  because his own body couldn't handle his  Quirk but Toya wanted to impress his  father so he kept training in secret at  about the age of 13 Toya disappeared and  was presumed dead after a massive fire  engulfed him while he was out training  Toya's body was believed to have been  burned to a crisp and only a small  fragment of his Jawbone was ever  recovered Endeavor and his entire family  believed that Toya was dead but he  turned up over a decade later as the  villain Dobby I'm working on a video  that will cover the complete story of  Dobby slash Toya including how he  survived the fire and became a villain  so if you want to know more subscribe  right now